presenting officer it is idiomatic that
a referendum must be lawful
but my deliberations in recent times
have led me to this further conclusion
the lawfulness or otherwise of the
referendum must be established as a
matter of fact not just opinion
otherwise as we have seen again in
recent days opposition parties will just
keep casting doubt on the legitimacy of
the process so that they can avoid the
substantive debate on independence which
scotland deserves but they so clearly
fear
that is not in the country's best
interest
let me turn that into the detail of the
steps we will now take to secure that
objective of an indisputably lawful
referendum
and then ensure that from today we can
focus on the substance of why scotland
should be independent
planning officer i can announce first of
all that the scottish government is
today publishing the scottish
independence referendum bill i will draw
attention in particular to three key
provisions of this bill
the purpose of the referendum i set out
in section one is to ascertain the views
of the people of scotland on whether or
not scotland should be an independent
country
in common with the 2014 referendum
indeed in common with the brexit
referendum and the referendum to
establish this parliament the
independence referendum proposed in the
bill will be consultative not
self-executing
just as in 2014 and recognized
explicitly in the 2013 white paper a
majority yes vote in this referendum
will not in and of itself make scotland
independent for scotland to become
independent following a yes vote
legislation would have to be passed by
the uk and scottish parliaments
now there has been much commentary in
recent days to the effect that a
consultative referendum would not have
the same status as the vote in 2014.
that is simply wrong factually and
legally let me be clear
the status of the referendum proposed in
this bill is exactly the same as the
referendums of 1997 2014 and 2016.
the next provision of the bill i wish to
draw attention to relates to the
question to be asked in the referendum
the bill states that the question on the
ballot paper should be
just as it was in 2014 should scotland
be an independent country
finally presiding officer the bill
includes the proposed date on which the
referendum should be held
in line with the government's clear
mandate this is a date within the first
half of this term of parliament
presenting officer akan announced that
the scottish government is proposing
that the independence referendum be held
on the 19th of october 2023
these are
thank you
thank you
members
these are the key elements of the
referendum legislation that the scottish
government wishes this parliament to
scrutinise and pass
let me turn now to the aim of
establishing as fact
the lawfulness of a referendum
which as i have members already
indicated i consider to be of the utmost
importance
i will start with what we know already
we know that the legislative competence
of the scottish parliament to pass this
bill in the absence of a section 30
order is contested we know that
legislative competence can only be
determined judicially
and we know that for as long as there is
no judicial determination opinions will
differ and doubt will continue to be
cast on the lawful basis for the
referendum that benefits only those
parties opposed to independence because
it allows them to avoid the substance of
the independence debate
finally we know that if this parliament
does seek to legislate without a section
30 order the bill will go to court that
is inevitable
the only questions are when it ends up
in court and at whose hand
if the issue of legislative competence
remains unresolved at the point of
formal introduction of a bill the uk
government will almost certainly use
section 33 of the scotland act to refer
it to the supreme court after it has
passed it is also possible that one or
more private individuals will lodge a
judicial review of the bill indeed it
was reported last week that tory
supporters are already planning to do so
a challenge by private individuals could
also go through successive courts and so
be a very lengthy process
either way at the point of parliament
passing the bill there would be no
certainty about when or even if it could
be implemented a court challenge would
still lie ahead and the timetable i have
set out today would quickly become
difficult to deliver
and of course between now and then claim
and counter claim
good faith arguments and bad faith
fear-mongering about so-called wild cat
referendums will continue to muddy the
water cast up doubt and taint the
process
deciding officer that may well suit
politicians opposed to independence but
none of it would be in the interest of
the country and none of it would serve
democracy
the fact is neither legal opinions nor
political arguments will resolve this
point
we must establish legal fact
that is why in my view we must seek now
to accelerate to the point when we have
legal clarity
legal fact and crucially in doing so i
hope establish and safeguard the ability
of this parliament to deliver a
referendum on the date proposed
presiding officer it is to this end that
some weeks ago i asked the lord advocate
to consider exercising the power she has
under paragraph 34 of schedule 6 to the
scotland act to refer to the supreme
court the question of whether the
provisions in this bill relate to
reserve matters this is a power
exercisable by the lord advocate alone
not by scottish ministers collectively
whether or not she does so is
accordingly a matter solely for her
however i can confirm that the lord
advocate has considered this request she
has taken into account the following
factors
this government's democratic mandate
the constitutional significance of this
issue the fact that the bill does raise
a genuine issue of law that is
unresolved and the importance of
ensuring that this government and
parliament act lawfully at all times and
she has now informed me of her decision
i can't advise parliament that the lord
advocate has agreed to make a reference
of the provisions in the bill to the
supreme court
indeed presiding officer as i speak the
process for serving the requisite
paperwork on the uk government by
lawyers and messengers at arms is
underway and i can confirm that the
reference will be filed with the supreme
court this afternoon